you're out there fighting with angelina
jolie it's like what else do you need
why not
the eternals are a group of superheroes
who've been around for at least 7 000
years created by the celestials sent to
earth to protect humankind from the
deviants fighting to prevent the end of
the world or the end of human
civilization as we know it so i don't
think the stakes get much higher than
that
[Music]
for me to be an eternal
has many different meanings as the
character it gives me a sense of duty
because i am in charge of the mission
and personally
it gives me
a sense of hope for change i am latino
and also arab and also in my 50s it
would've been almost unimaginable that
i would become a superhero now
i feel like what it means to be an
eternal is becoming a reflection of
people
who have been here and i think that the
eternals let people have an insight into
how wonderful humankind has been
if i could i would only work with chloe
job from here on out if chloe called me
and was like hey i'm just gonna put you
in everything i do i would be like great
it's an incredible group that came
together to make this film we all come
from very different backgrounds and
cultures and it's an amazing mix of
people once we finally came together
we're all in our super suits and got to
see each other it was the most amazing
amazing experience i think i cried like
i think like i think i cried and um it
still is one of the most memorable
moments i've ever had it's like a big
family
everyone was lovely and a big movie of
that scale is a bit intimidating to go
on to chloe was our captain she listened
and took my ideas on building the action
great teamwork great communication i was
very happy
[Music]
she shows her primary super strength to
be a speedster
but also very intelligent
i think that's combination of both of
those makes makari very powerful
how am i alike or different from my
curse well very different i can't fly i
can't shoot lasers out my eyes i don't
have super strength all of the things i
would very much like to have my
character
although she's an alien and doesn't have
any children has a very strong sense of
motherhood for the rest of the eternals
and i have always said that
she likes to boss people around and i
have always had that too
she's a free spirit she's very loyal i
would say i have quite a lot of overlap
with
with her actually
[Music]
one of my favorite moments to shoot i
suppose was a
was filming in in camden in london where
i was on a crane on wires and i'm flying
and landing on the street and that was
kind of
uh it was really fun just because i'm
above the bridge in camden and you get
to see this kind of bird's eye view of
streets that have walked for many years
so i got to see her from a different
angle i am excited to see the spectacle
and the big action pieces and also the
kind of more intimate
character driven beats as well
this is an incredibly epic movie i mean
the scale of it the story of it is
unlike anything i think marvel has ever
done before as far as ensembles go this
is one of the best ensembles i've ever
been with you know it was incredibly
emotional ride which i think the viewer
will experience when they watch it
because it's thousands of years in the
making
[Music]
[Music]
you